there's something for me that I feel
like with comedy I'm just kind of like
it leaves something to be desired for um
just yeah yeah I agree with that I'll
try my dump up there it doesn't go well
do you ever say something too real and
people are just like no man we don't
relate to that you should get some help
like when I talk about like kids getting
beat like Christian Youth in the midwest
like they just some of them get it
others are like what's your angle you're
talking about like childhood just like
getting beat as a kid no not me but like
you're talking about beating up children
yeah oh oh right when I pivot to that
thing
no I bring a kid up there yeah the
demonstration as well yeah that's what I
want to go towards is things that people
go you can't talk about that and it's
like well that's because getting beat as
a kid is so [ __ ] awful and there are
kids getting beat and we do need to talk
about it and yeah we're not making fun
of the victims of it we're talking about
it's a thing that's unless they make a
weird noise then it's funny yeah I'm
sorry